here's a guy right here dude here's my
boy Carl Lentz no this is also the guy
from don't [ __ ] with cats that I voted
me no you didn't die he didn't do you my
suicide
no you went to prison he should have I
think his I forget how tense oh how do
you have ideas and I'm like wow he has
them this Frozone last week yeah
damn that's amazing Wow is he dead
though Nick the people's pastor right
there dog I think he looks like him that
you win this round he wishes he looked
like the Lord's [ __ ] you think I'll find
out what she looks like the Lord's [ __ ]
boy I like that guy I do like him the
Lord's bad boy huh please please get me
in heaven yeah bro you got it you should
have read that down before you said it
because I really want to be there no I
do ball roll Paul out there dog Paul
wall I got Paul what's your guy hold
yours would be my friend Paul wall Paul
George would be my friend Paul Bunyan
son no dog all right let's hear what
this guy's to say then here's somebody
right here you called this is you get
you got this guy do we do it's not a
Masucci don't let me forget ya japanese'
my name is James I come from Scotland
afraid of all these baby my king or
stinger is quite simple
the Scottish accent king or stinger Gang
Gang buzz buzz
or glass regions would see okay gang
buzz-buzz peace and love
brothers something's going on there that
I don't know I know what's going on
that's easy murder murder of cats this
guy owns a couple extra knives if you
know what I'm saying right oh oh you
like this knife pocket on my pants Mike
I don't think you supposed to put a
knife in that pocket it's just a regular
pocket you can put a knife in any pocket
uh thank you for the message from
Scotland dude you know Scotland or is
Brendan or as I like to call it
Brendan's brea cancer going back to the
motherland dude shoutout to the white
motherland Scotland I want to say what
is he asking about is he oh no just his
accent in general Scottish accent
Scotland Braveheart
lightly yeah that's right brave William
Wallace yeah well it is very I love you
always have I love you I love you come
on do it
haha that's a little Schwartz in a right
okay they don't have any Swartz and
naggers in Scotland dude okay first of
all that's a fact that's a fact
yeah never seen a black guy in Scotland
black out what you mean I'm talking like
the Austrians Austrians Austrians ooh
I'm just saying I've never seen a black
guy in Scotland have you have you been
there yeah they have a couple blank
Scots I don't think so like Scottish man
I'm sure there's one but you don't see a
lot of them you don't see a lot dude but
you could you'd be a black Scot man I
feel like oh I will for sure
will he [ __ ] acts like years Brooke
he shouldn't be faking it so much
there's a guy right there what about
that shirtless guy up there
Brennan's a little buddy right
this little Soglin sugar sickle gobbling
[ __ ] in your face
check out that trouser snake dude got
the bagpipes I'm Brad
it's crazy Brendan Brendan biked up on
this he would just just stop and film
the guy's [ __ ] for about 13 seconds I'm
sure yeah look at this thing I think
it's pregnant since I like Scottish
accents I like Scottish accents too
because you can get at like especially
if you come to like if you come to
another country to go to another country
you can get out of anything nobody knows
you're talking about you don't know what
you're talking about it's a win-win you
know and they basically just took the
Irish accent and they're like we don't
want to be Irish we need to make it we
need our own thing yeah and it's like
hey I'm gonna talk Irish woman somebody
punched me in the face while I'm talking
yeah so you have a guy who's just like
oh he's just like talking and Scottish
you know and he's like yeah I'm gonna go
King it man I came the [ __ ] out of it I
think chicks dig the accent too right
cat yeah do you why I like accents in
general yeah mmm most chicks dig an
accent Sean Connery we see Scottish he's
Scottish I'll tell you who else is
Scottish dude um the late great Gerry
Gerard Butler that's right from 300 yep
I'll also tell you another Scotsman
Jonathan Davis from corn he plays the
bagpipes he does yeah okay
is he Scottish I don't know it's not
smooth yeah yeah it's pretty Scottish I
would say master from awesome power is
he really okay how do you know it he
says it what are you some squaddies yep
I'm Scotty Oh Oh get in my bed
my belly b-billy get my belly Gerard
Butler I want to also tell you who the
famous late-night talk-show host Craig
Ferguson is a Scot ah he might be the
best one I like that guy
no I'm gonna go Jerry Butler dude really
yeah 300 300 yeah who else is out there
who's another famous Scot dude shut out
Scotland yet they don't even have
usually they have like an arrow and you
can scroll through they don't even have
that option they just have these six
people that's amazing online let me take
group there there should be proud of
that
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah don't see a lot
of bagpipes these days if you go to a
corn concert you'll see a bagpipe yeah
get out more yeah yeah quarantine that's
what they should call the next one
yeah all right 14 great idea I love you
like corn oh all right I'll do this
let's put this up on the thing hanger
sing it for the audience corn the band
or corn Kon or cor head they are is
backwards you know yeah corn the banner
corn the meal or the Quran put it up
yeah dude three on tipeee twitter or the
quran and then do just the two on
instagram oh yeah okay here's this guy
like a nice fresh corn don't you get my
teeth oh I like or man I like corn a
sweet corn
do you remember did you ever have when
you're growing up corn and milk
sorry timeout creamed [ __ ]
I love Christmas aside with the steak
the creamed corn is just corn and milk
right not really
yeah I think your mouth ko is captain
crunch crunch tastes like [ __ ] but it's
still pretty good
yeah yeah that homemade dinner time
captain
[Music]